Frances I'm gonna start off with you if
that's okay yep and how easy or
difficult was it to conclude this this
amazing story you know it easy in the
sense that we all love the source
material and we all wanted to make the
book so the the adaptation process I
mean always has challenges but we always
knew the direction that we were gonna go
in obviously this chapter is a very
complicated chapter so there were big
challenges in the making of the movie I
was shot over three countries really
challenging sequences had a really rough
winter obviously lost in actors so there
were plenty of complexities and you know
emotional drops in the making of this
but the adaptation process was great and
some and from the last film and not the
sewer scene okay yeah what was what was
your favorite scene to film from this
last film my favourite scene well that's
a really good question I think I mean
the sewer scene is the one that sticks
out I mean that's all I can think about
what I think that's all I remember
I mean these guys were great but
seriously the sort of struggles that we
went through the yeah we went we went to
a dark place I think we all do it
together we were holding each other's
hands but it was it was really really
tough shoot and all I could think about
pretty much through Catching Fire was
where I had to go with this character
and I had that I had that at the end of
that you know at the end of the sewers
but yeah it was a really really sort of
tough shoot and then we basically feel I
feel that we spent three weeks just
sprinting through very claustrophobic
and small and cold at the same time hot
bizarrely as sue is yeah so I mean I
thought all my training everything that
I
sort of prepared I suppose from the
beginning was all kind of building up to
that point so it was not only my
favorite scene but like you know the
hardest opportunity to film in Paris and
Berlin he was amazing so all that stuff
was exciting to shoot yeah always comes
back to the series boy Liam with Gael
what I mean that scene and just how how
you played that senior it towards the
end I think you know the one I'm talking
about what happened to him
it's you know it's basically the
realization that he's finally lost her
you know I think he realizes that he
went too far and and did something that
she always disagreed with and yes it's
them it's it's sort of the last goodbyes
between them not to ruin the story for
anyone yeah it's quite emotional and
it's a goodbye for both of them and Josh
the character Peter and is in this
particular film and was there a lot of
discussion between yourself and Francis
about this journey that he has on this
chapter and these places that you have
to go as an actor for that character
yeah I mean a lot of it was in the books
you know
the script in Hanley you know when I
first read the the books that was a
thing I loved about Pia so much was the
the arc you got to go on and going from
being this extremely trustworthy
character that everyone can depend upon
to this really twisted almost you know
bipolar on the edge kind of character I
think the biggest thing that Francis and
I really talked about was like what
happened to him in the capital that he
talked about what actual tortures he
experienced and I don't know once you
once you kind of started thinking in
that way and start understanding what he
went through it kind of just became a
part of the character and I mean to have
this idea that you literally don't know
which memories are real and which ones
are real you know it's it's that's a
really psychologically twisted and dark
and terrifying I think those are thing
that those are important was that they
came across that Peeta was afraid of
himself and and so that's kind of the
direction we're trying to go with it and
then with having I'm gonna bring you in
Haymitch I mean we're so thrilled that
you're here as well to talk about this
film I've personally been wanting to ask
you about being part of this film for a
number of films but we're glad you're
here thank you for being here what is
what is his motivation he stuck around
he's been there for these these people
what's his motivation well first of all
I want to thank you for thinking about
thinking of me as Woody Allen that's
really second
yeah the motivation I think is you know
initially I get to know these guys and
I'm you know not wanting to befriend
them because I know they're gonna die in
the early you know in the first film and
then eventually of course I fall in love
with them these guys and so I want to
help them in this terrible world we live
in and and and be a mentor to them and
then at the same time I have this
awareness before they do that there's
gonna be a revolution you know and so
trying to navigate things with that
knowledge ahead of time it was I as
boring as I sounded and finally next I
have the parties the night before
Stanley and season where I was asleep
for a minute I want to see the Caesar
spin-off show that kind of sees our
hosts like Panem's Got Talent or
something that would be up for it Oh
without question yeah he needs his own
clothing range for sure yeah and what
why does he not have any do you think he
has Canada Tunya sympathy for the
revolution and for cognizant yeah I
think he does I think he does have
sympathy for them I think he has you
know there's he empathizes to a certain
extent but he has no real moral Center
so and he's the guy who just wants to be
on the winning side you know I mean if
if were pushed you know came to shove he
would and you know there were a dead
rebel laying next to him you know as the
rest of the rebels are coming in he'd
take off his clothes and put that guy's
clothes home and put his clothes on that
guy yeah he's that kind of person and
pretend he was a different person yeah
no matter how many times the regime
changed he'd be on the winning side okay
we're gonna throw it to audience whole
middle section we've got some that
competition winners but I'd like to
start our conference by going to Sarah
Miliband if that's okay she's been
invited along today by Make A Wish
charity Sam what will you miss about
playing Finnick Wow
I tell you one thing I won't miss the
sewers I will miss the sort of the
physical life of Finnick I think I think
the opportunity to kind of play you know
to play quite literally and fight people
and to hit people was really fun I mean
I unfortunately did that for real once
and broke a finger but you know
nonetheless it was all worth it and I
think when you watch two films I think
it's that side of it that I personally
enjoyed enjoyed filming the most but I
enjoy watching the most because there is
a part you know you do challenge
yourself you absolutely push yourself to
the limits but it shows I think I think
we all put our heart and soul into this
we all will a lot of blood sweat and
tears especially in the sewers and yeah
I think I think it would be all the
fighting you know I can only hope that I
get the opportunity to play with the
Trident again it's very rare I think and
actually during filming the one thing I
will say I really struggled with was
running around with a stick when
everyone else had a gun we were holding
each other's hands most the time I don't
know how much damage I could have done
really close close combat in the sewers
just to mention the sewers okay thank
you thank you sir thank you okay we got
a to competition winners first up Olivia
where's Olivia hi Olivia
Jonah stand up there we go get
microphone and who's your question for
please
question I just think there's a lot of
emotional scenes in the whole trilogy
how did you feel the emotional scenes
yeah I mean you know I think um I don't
know your job as an actor is to is to
bring emotion into the story I think and
and to move it along and so anytime you
get to have the opportunity to have big
emotional swings and a scene more and
dramatic events are happening
it's always fun I mean it's the moment
we get to show the most of the character
the moment you get to kind of lose
yourself and most into the character and
that's like my favorite part about
acting is when you kind of forget where
you are and what you're doing and you
know what's happening around you and you
just are in that moment existing
organically and and and so for me I
always enjoyed those scenes there
sometimes some of the more difficult
scenes especially there's a lot
happening around you it's hard to to
focus and to but yes really enjoyable to
do and when you have actors like Jin who
maybe doesn't take things the most
seriously between takes it definitely
makes it even an added layer of
challenge but the crazy things with her
it's like you're joking joking joking
all of a sudden she like snaps it into
like completely they're in the moment
and like disappears in the character but
no I really I really enjoyed those bits
of the filming for sure yeah I actually
would after that - I think part of the
fun of these movies and part of what
makes these movies great is the contrast
between the intimate and the epic and so
I think we all really enjoyed focusing
on the characters and focusing on the
emotional journeys and not just the sort
of scope and scale of the stories as
well thank you so much next one is
Karina where's Karina hi Karina if you
go Mike
if someone were to join a franchise like
mind games what advice would you give to
them someone were to join franchise like
Hunger Games bring bring the sense of
humor don't be too serious because yo
you'll get thrown to the Wolves if you
do that yeah I think I think the best
thing about this franchise was was not
only was it important and it had great
messages for young people and all people
we were all able to make such good
friends with each other
and going through something like this
where you go from you know really
extreme situations to really live
situations it's just you know it's one
one extreme situation to the other and I
think for us it made it so much easier
and more joy enjoyable because we love
being around each other and we had our
best friends there to support us and
especially you know Josh Jenna and I
coming into it in the first one the
first tool was really overwhelming and
you know it's very hard to kind of get
used to you know you get thrown you
thrown into such an extreme situation so
I think we had each other there and made
it a lot easier if you can make friends
with you Castle Thanks make friends
another laughs basically okay we can
open up to the floor nice so if you have
a question please raise your hand we've
got a microphone to you don't do that
thing I've wait until the last minute
there we go gentlemen right next to Tom
you know hey I think this is the last we
will see of the Hunger Games franchise
in the cinema everyone Frances yeah I
think you know we we finished the
story's out it's it's kind of
bittersweet for us you know we all left
making the movies we all love to be in
together but I'm very very happy to have
seen his stories through to the end so
if there were ever more stories I think
they have to come from Suzanne Collins
you know she has to have to have a new
idea and theme that she's interested in
and figure out new stories to tell there
in the world
PanAm more around the world of Katniss
and these characters I mean if she did
if she came up with something I'd be in
in a second so write letters to her who
do you want to pick up well can you talk
to her about it I could use the work my
name is Cassidy I'm from the FPS which
is all military and I'm bettering myself
the military's in this film you all most
of you sorry stemming most of you play
pretty worried worried people I'm
curious about you know the military's
kind of portrayed a negative way in this
film I'm curious about your own opinions
on the military and whether you do any
inspiration from from the military to
create your characters yeah I'm not
positive that the military's portrayed
in it in a in a negative way in this
film I think war is portrayed in a
negative way in this movie right and
some of the leaders are portrayed in a
negative way I wouldn't say the military
is all nothing and I think none of us
have anything but respect for people in
the military so I just wanted to clarify
that for us it's the it's more
thematically about the consequence of
war and violence and exploring what that
does to people emotionally and
physically I think I think what happens
a lot of times in movies is it gets
glorified and war gets glorified and and
I think the danger of that is is you
don't understand the full consequence of
it I mean for me it's all about you do
everything you possibly can before you
get to the point where you're risking
lives and I think in this movie you see
the sacrifice people have to make you
see the the intense process they have to
go through when they are faced with the
actual war and so I think for me that
that's really what a big part of this
movie wasn't the consequence of war and
the dangers of it and trying to explore
every avenue and avoid all these
conflicts and things that get you into a
violent confrontation thank you and then
lady at the back please
Thanks I'm Anna Faris from the Daily
Telegraph this is actually late to that
question I wondered if I could ask
anybody who wants to answer about the
levels of violence in the film over here
it will be seen by children 12 upwards
you can't escape the fact that this it's
quite psychologically and physically
disturbing in parts on the other hand we
live in a world with real Wars where
young where children are really going
through not dissimilar things I wondered
how you decided where to draw the line
and what you think is appropriate that
was probably the biggest challenge that
I had in the making of this of this
movie specifically I think each of the
movies has been violent in its own way I
knew this was gonna be the toughest and
going back again to the source material
you know Susanna wrote these books with
the intention of writing about the
consequence of war for teenagers and so
you go to make a movie about the same
thing and I think part of the reason
that books are so popular is that she
did not flinch
she didn't patronize kids she didn't
flinch at the telling of the stories and
that her treatment of the themes and so
I felt like we couldn't either but in
the visual interpretation the stories I
wanted to make sure that we were again
focusing on the emotional consequence of
it not the carnage not the blood if
you've all seen the movie you'll notice
there's a very very little blood that's
not what I wanted to explore it's not
what I'm interested in and that's kind
of that became my guide for the visual
treatment of violence in the film
you